il y a son truc sur la tête là bon mon
truc c'est la meilleure chose
c'est très joli
aire du meilleur one man show lundi
dernier
sur France 2 en direct pour l'homme au
mille visages c'est lui alors ça c'est
le pire ça c'est le truc le plus normal
alors comme les gens connaissent pas
tous encore bien que vous ayez beaucoup
de succès vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
succès vous étiez à Marigny il a fallu
prolonger à Mogador vous êtes un
transformiste le transformiste ça
commence au 16ème siècle ensuite ça a
été repris par la commedia della alors
raconté un peu comment ça a commencé
c'est-à-dire le type qui suit le patron
qui suit son employé l'autre se cache
dans une caisse la base de la chose la
transformisme le premier c'était
l'acteur italien c'est sur une place
publique il changeait de masque qui
faisait plusieurs personnages s'appelait
Giovanni Gabriel et le curieux c'est
qu'il avait deux fils donc ils étaient
assis sur le coin de son plateau à la
fin demandait un petit saut si tu sais
pas pour moi c'est pour ces beaux
enfants et le plus grand de ses enfants
c'était scapino donc le plus grand
commun
du 17e siècle donc tu vois ça c'est le
début du transformisme et après il y a
eu effectivement au 19e siècle
il y avait tu sais Tabarin c'était un
comique italien qui est sur le quai de
la Seine faisait numéro de chapeau
échangé de chapeau beaucoup de fois moi
je reprends ce numéro et je change 27
fois de chapeau donc c'est une
arc-en-ciel mais très rare parce que bon
le secret sont maintenus très très
secret justement il y a des gens que
j'ai commencé je ne connaissais pas mais
je sais moi aussi chez elle est prête
six ans chez le séminaire j'avais les
bonnes soeurs qui faisait le maquillage
j'étais terrible alors ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que c'est pas seulement un
défilé de costume
je vais raconter quelque chose vous avez
fait au National à Londres c'est un
ouvrier qui qui se transforme en soldat
à ce moment-là il explose et il devient
sa mère en noir qui donc il y a une
émotion qui est même au-delà de la
surprise
plusieurs fois dans dans un spectacle
parce que en Italie je suis entendu par
l'État oui je fais des spectateurs des
fois je fais Shakespeare des fois donc
des fois c'est très sérieux et dans la
transformation se devient un moyen
théâtral et cette fois un national
frites je veux juste ce soldats perdu
dans une usine de bombe et qui il voyait
la guerre encore une fois donc redevenez
soldat et puis pendant qu'il revoyait le
moment où il était blessé il crée maman
noire avec une bougie qui pleurait et là
tout le monde moi il y avait le noir fin
première acte je sortais de scène il y
avait pas d'applaudissement à rien je
dis on a raté par contre les gens ils
étaient tellement surpris qu'à la fin
c'était le mélange de surprise visuelle
des très belles alors vous dites c'est
très italien de se changer parce que
finalement c'est pour plaire au dernier
conquérant et c'est vrai que l'Italie a
tellement été occupé que alors vous
voulez pas avouer votre date de
naissance
dans un village à 40 km de Turin vous
étiez un enfant timide maigre vous étiez
nul au football
j'ai pris ma réva 11 ans vous rentrez au
séminaire va d'abord le Petit Séminaire
puis après le Grand Séminaire chez les
Salésiens et c'est un curé donne
mantelli qui vous a initié la magie et
vous étiez tellement gentil tellement un
bon élève qui lui a donné les clés de
son bureau et à Tours il est allé dans
le bureau encore maintenant tu sais
c'est un prêtre business ben fantastique
il fait 300 spectacles par année il a
adopté ça enfin au troisième monde et
alors quand vous êtes adolescent votre
foi Vassy c'est-à-dire que vous vouliez
vous voulez plus être patte à un moment
vous commencez l'adolescence vous serez
l'envie vous perdez l'envie d'être pape
oui parce que bon j'avais les clés tu
faisais du sûreté du séminaire tous les
deux jours du séminaire vous étiez
figurant à l'Opéra et là vous connaissez
toute ma vie mais oui mais vous êtes une
vous avez des espions
c'est intéressant vous dites aujourd'hui
quand on vous parle vous donc vous
faites le mur et aujourd'hui quand on
vous parle de la religion vous dites
j'irai brûler avec le reste de mes amis
donc vous avez bien quitté la religion
là ben tu sais la religion ça suffit
d'avoir un sentiment religieux puisque
c'est à là aux yeux Jéhovah c'est une
relative d'accord les gens se désignent
de vie et de tête c'est tout alors
l'opéra évidemment vous découvrez un
autre univers avec le séminaire vous
découvrez les cantatrices obsédées
sexuelles vous découvrirez le torero
dans la Carmen ah on va en avoir un
après vous découvrir les metteurs héros
mais le vrai escam au milieu c'était un
gros pas possible sur
un chanteur ténor et nous avons été
défigurants très maigre très fin il y
avait des oui et tu sais que les les
chanteurs d'opéra ils se donnent des
petites coups derrière enfin non
pourquoi
des petits signes pour finir la note en
même temps sinon l'autre il y a un qui
dure plus longtemps alors c'est l'autre
je me demandais toujours comment ils
arrivaient à finir oui alors ils font le
duo il se touchent des relais mains ils
font ils
signe et ils finissent ensemble et alors
un jour vous êtes découvert enfin vous
n'êtes pas découvert vous êtes déjà
connu mais c'est Majax Gérard majac
Majax on connaît bien et alors il vous
trouve il fait il va toujours voir les
congrès des magiciens voilà donc lui il
avait mal à la tête les copains italiens
dit regarde ce numéro avant de partir et
puis ma présentait j'aimerais rivière
qui m'a pris au Paradis là au Paradis
Latin alors là évidemment vous vous
arrivez puis après bon on va pas
raconter toute votre carrière
c'était bien moi j'ai connu l'Alcazar
douche commune douche commune déjà le
premier jour ça commence bien
par personne c'était bien parce que
après c'est un succès mondial
même une sitcom pour Hollywood non
maintenant
il y a deux mois et donc
je vais faire les 10 prochains les 10
prochaines avec la Warner Bros avec Bad
bannir la cantine
alors on va faire une interview vous
avez pas bouger
[Musique]
bien on s'appelle lardivio pensez à quoi
là
qu'est-ce que la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher
j'ai répondu à mes emails enfin la
dernière dernière non la dernière
dernière c'est pas ça
le matin quand vous vous voyez dans
votre glace dans votre miroir vous dites
quoi je suis une vampire le matin c'est
vraiment
la salle de bain vous dormez beaucoup
oui je dors 8 9 heures je pense que
c'est juste qu'est-ce que vous
changeriez en vous si vous aviez une
baguette magique en beaucoup de choses
physiques surtout moi vous êtes
vachement bien
écoute Emma il est très bien je trouve
bon il y a son truc sur la tête là bon
mon truc c'est le meilleur chose
quelle est la phrase que vous ne
supportez pas d'entendre
je supporte pas les gens quand ils
parlent des trucs qu'ils ont fait c'est
pas vrai tu vois j'aime pas cette forme
de le côté du show-business que je
connais bien parce que bon je vois plein
de gens où ils veulent des trucs des
autres gens qu'est-ce qui vous énerve le
plus chez vous chez moi où est la chose
de vous que vous ne supportez pas
des fois je m'énerve de pas c'est
méchant avec les autres parce que de
temps en temps il faut
bon et qu'est-ce qui vous énerve le plus
chez moi je vous connais pas encore
est-ce que vous êtes déjà senti le
maître du monde
sûrement tout le monde car il joue un
jeu vidéo Game c'est à ce moment-là
est-ce que vous êtes déjà senti une
ou quoi une ah
c'était mon nouveau mot bien compris
oui oui oui mec c'est quand vraiment je
dis une grand mensonge quelque chose de
vous sentez une est-ce que
vous préférez draguer ou vous faire
draguer ou draguer
est-ce que vous préférez larguer ou
faire larguer
normalement je suis largué
parce que je vais trop vite dans la
drogue
alors je dois je veux connaître
quelqu'un bien mais
j'ai pas de temps alors comment vous
aimeriez mourir moi sur scène avec une
tu vois ce gros lustre qui me tombe sur
la tête d'accord je pensais bien en
direct et les en plus ça te fait de ça
fait des archives pour les enfants de la
télé
[Rires]
Arthur pendant des années il va repasser
nos bouts d'émission
dernière question Henriette réincarner
en quel personnage que vous incarnez sur
scène
mais quand j'étais petit j'ai pensé
d'être saint François prêt incarner je
sais pas pourquoi
non
pas d'oiseaux pas de pas de barbe pas de
pas de vie simple donc je sais pas
pourquoi voudri être un ange oui je veux
j'ai déjà fait plusieurs fois là je sur
scène ça me plaît beaucoup à plus comme
vu que je vole parce que j'ai plusieurs
machines pour voler à la maison
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu